okay last question today hey David how
do you feel about the youngbae movement
going on in cities like Washington DC
San Francisco and elsewhere so Jim
becomes from NIMBY NIMBY means not in my
backyard there was a lot of discussion
about NIMBY here in Massachusetts
surrounding the Cape Wind project which
would have put a bunch of wind farms far
enough offshore of Cape Cod that they
would have been about an inch or half an
inch in your sort of vertical horizon
from shore and there was a big movement
that claimed to be politically
progressive and wanting alternative
energy but was saying yeah but not in my
backyard not off the coast of the of
Cape Cod where I would see it NIMBY now
has a corollary called or a counterpart
called EMV which is yes in my backyard
and that movement is one that seeks to
solve a number of different housing and
economic issues that are going on
including hugely overinflated or if not
overinflated escalated increased housing
prices partially as a result of under
supply of affordable housing and the ENB
movement is a movement that is based on
sort of an understanding of how if you
make housing more affordable in general
even if it's yes in your backyard with
affordable housing or the type of
housing that rich people might not
always want right next to them that it's
actually going to solve a lot of
problems and reduce negative
externalities and better crime data etc
etc so I am basically a MB type person
ever since living in New York and even
now in Boston I live in places I want to
live in all of which are in close
proximity to mixed income buildings
public housing for individuals who are I
believe it I know section eight I never
remember if section eight is a local
term or a federal term but low income
housing and it's never occurred to me to
look to live elsewhere as a result of
that I've never encountered any issues
as a result of that I welcome when there
is a new building in condo Ville Boston
which is where I live coming in where
half of the units are going to be
reserved for people with family incomes
household incomes under $70,000 for
example meaning it could be two people
making $30,000
I think that all those things are good
and I think that the more I read and
since last week's live calls I've
actually been reading a lot more because
we got a question about this about what
can be done to deal with the hugely
exploded housing prices supply is
actually a big part of it there are
other regulatory things that can be done
and there's many other ideas but you've
got to increase the supply of housing
that actually is a big part of it and
it's got to be relatively affordable
housing so I am in favor of the Y MB
movement yes in my backyard although I
don't literally have a backyard because
there's other apartments there but if I
had a backyard I would say go ahead and
build there why not thanks to everybody
who submitted questions we've got a
great bonus show for you today get
access to the bonus show by becoming a
member at join pakman.com or becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show